raid bosses are fun nothing quite
captures the intensity of a climactic
boss fight than raid bosses where people
work together to take down a gigantic
enemy these team versus giant fights
always get my blood pumping and the
gamer in me just gets a surge of
adrenaline it's then appropriate that
for today's list i'll be doing a rundown
of some of my favorite team vs gigantic
enemy fights in anime so what fights are
you expecting to see make sure to tell
me in the comments section below but why
restrict overcoming those insurmountable
challenges to your favorite anime
characters you can take those challenges
yourself by downloading today's sponsor
lord of heroes lord of heroes is the hit
mobile rpg that puts you in the role of
a monarch set to revolutionize the world
first off let me just say that there's
no doubt that anime fans like you would
find comfort in designs like those i
mean i certainly did and it was those
that got me to try the game out only for
me to get more than what i bargained for
for march's update lord of heroes
introduces the new story event war of
the tyrants here players get to go back
in time take part in the titular war of
the tyrants and take part in the events
that help shape the present unravelling
secrets as they go joining the fray
would be the elven archmage lucillica
now in her all-new dark element form a
constantly evolving story characters
that look all sorts of cool and a very
immersive battle system make lord of
heroes a must play if you're in any way
interested in this kind of genre and i
know you are since you're all here so i
suggest heading down to the description
box downloading the game and giving lord
of heroes a try
let's start with attack on titan shall
we
attack on titan being a show that
features a lot of well titan fights has
no shortage of raid battles against
monsters that tower over man there are
so many candidates here so i'd like to
turn our attention to an underrated
scene from the first season the final
annie fight
back when everything was simpler the
time when aot had yet to show its full
repertoire in storytelling beats and
were all drawn to the tension-filled
survival battles against titans the ani
fight sets itself apart from the other
fights in this list and instead of
people fighting against the gigantic foe
we have aaron giving the good guys some
much needed firepower he goes toe to toe
with annie while the survey corpse all
work together to help subdue any once
and for all with how much more aot has
proven itself to be it's easy to
overlook this moment in the modern days
but back then this was an epic finale
for the smash hit the ears attack on
titan
[Music]
we can't leave fate out of this now can
we here's gorgon
you know i'm really tempted to put the
diamond fight here but i figured that i
talked about that fight enough and
wanted to give the spotlight to the
other giant boss fight in the series
gorgon the notable part about this fight
is how it happens early to show us an
idea of the villain's power at that
point we're led to believe that gorgon
is the diamond we've been hearing about
and her power certainly hints to them
leonidas and ushiwakamaru both tried
their best but even with their best shot
they're just no match hey at least they
made an epic show out of it though right
little did we know that things were
about to get worse especially when the
real theomath shows up we haven't seen
anything yet
princess connect makes its explosive
debut in these fight lists
princess connectors i've often described
it is wholesome konosuba it's very chill
less degenerate and is basically about a
group of friends having easy going
adventures together that is until stuff
starts getting real towards the end of
season one and parts of season two we
start uncovering a conspiracy and
learning the truth about the world and
yuki's memories oh and the fight scenes
for season two have been turned up a
notch and this fight is a prime example
of that the shadows give the characters
a chance to show off what they've got
and the golem leading them serves as the
big unbeatable obstacle that pushes them
in a race against time the whole thing
looks very well done and could have
caught people off guard not too
different from the kobayashi's dragon
maid fight if you remember that all that
finishing off with one of the most
breathtaking animation sequences of
pekkarine's finishing blow it certainly
looks ufo tables the way the scene was
done
here's something you probably haven't
predicted to see
legend of the millennium dragon's final
fight i believe deserves its spot on the
list what is legend of the millennium
dragon you ask well it's a 2011 film
that feels like one of the few
precursors to the time travel isakai
subgenre before it was cool boy travels
back in time and takes part in a war
between factions it's got the
traditional japanese aesthetic the
samurai and the demons and a whole lot
of mysticism it's also got some twists
that i won't call completely
unpredictable but hey it's there overall
i feel that the highlight of the movie
is the final battle going into more
details would be a spoiler but let's say
that it's a culmination on par with what
you'd expect out of this movie everyone
throwing what they have at the villain
the daunting atmosphere of the whole
thing and the finish brought about by
some help from the heavens if you've got
an hour and a half to burn and you're
into time travel fantasy it's a guy then
you should definitely try watching this
movie
speaking of fantasy why don't we check
out this dunmuchi moment
fantasy with some game mechanics a
gigantic boss fight feels completely at
home here the goliath fight in danmachi
is one of my favorite moments in the
show and it has a lot to do with the
whole build-up for comparison sakes
whereas the sao moment a while ago
dazzled us with cool visuals and
callbacks to erase that we loved this
one makes full use of the atmosphere the
tension it's really so hype seeing ryu
and bell fight together and the fight
has no shortage of drama pick a best
moment seriously is it the finishing
move or the number of tough sacrifices
done in this battle however if there's
anything to take away from the fight
it's the explanation for the sword it's
got some people questioning it but
that's just the thing with ellen
adaptations still even as an anime first
i really enjoyed this battle
next we go on to a slightly different
take of our ancient historical kingdoms
in muggy
margie's as a series is for me one of
the best shonen in the 2010s not even a
biased take and i feel that it's grossly
underrated considering how it
masterfully combines adventure action
politics and a whole lot of cool
character designs it's fitting that we
had one big raid boss fight to cap off
its anime run what i like about this
fight is that it really gives off the
aura of finality we know it's not the
final battle but with how over the top
everything is it provides a perfect
payoff to this anime we had almost all
named characters flowing in getting
their moments to show off yet ultimately
falling to off the medium it's one
dynamic entry after another culminating
with sinbad and the entire seven seas
alliance coming to the rescue it's a fun
ride that spanned a couple of episodes
and it just drives the magnitude of the
battle home
next is ores versus straw hats
when it comes to one piece fights we
often talk about those big one-on-one
fights however in a world where pretty
much anything's possible it's no
surprise that the straw hats would run
themselves into giant threats kaido is
one but i want to talk about the oars
fight it's a multi-part battle wherein
the straw hats take their fair share of
elves thanks to the immense power of
ores luffy soon joins the fight and even
then they find themselves in such a
pickup it took everything from the straw
hats to finally beat them and it felt
like such an earned victory with him no
selling everything episode after episode
him falling after that final giant
bazooka gave me the thrill of seeing a
raid boss finally fought in the video
games i played
next we have sao's final fight in
ordinal scale
it's no secret that i really like sao
now with this anime officially turning a
decade old in a short while a lot has
been said about the franchise a rather
uncommon opinion that i hold however is
that ordinal scale is somewhere up there
as one of the best sao anime that we've
got it's got everything you'd want from
a movie it builds on the acclaimed first
part of season 1 gives us a movie that's
generally self-contained and well paced
and of course finish off with what i
feel is the best boss fight the
franchise had you're talking the real
last boss of aincrad here a monstrosity
that not even kirito and friends could
beat on their own at first then everyone
from every game they played came in and
it was a real raid for the ages most of
the characters get their highlight shots
in and the kirito arsuna finish was just
perfect even if you've tuned out of sao
i still encourage you to watch this film
it recaptures the magic and condenses
everything in a nice movie with a mix of
everything drama action romance and some
fan service
that's got to do it for this list if you
have some giant fights that i've missed
then don't hesitate to tell me in the
comments actually you know what why stop
with just commenting i know comments are
good for the algorithm and i appreciate
that but i'd also invite you to come and
join us and hop on to our social media
whether it be the vini tube discord
channel instagram or patreon don't
forget to check out our sponsors of this
video lord of heroes the links in the
description thanks for watching and i
hope to see you next time stay safe stay
strong and stay awesome
you